three two one hi this is kristin press
and i'm here
in my hometown in southern california
and i'm gonna show you how i spend a day
off with my wells fargo active cash visa
card which earns me
unlimited two percent cash rewards on
purchases
let's go
so we just walked up the street and we
are gonna do some
clothes shopping and have a good time
[Music]
i have my own streetwear brand so i like
to check out what else going on in the
world of sweatpants
and cool streetwear free inc is a brand
that i started with some of my teammates
owning a small business is actually
quite like football
whenever you succeed you just see what's
coming up next that's why i love it i
love being challenged i love learning
well i think this is what i'm gonna get
got my sweat set
thank you absolutely
[Music]
i'm here in venice at garrett light
looking at some sunnies and maybe some
new blue light glasses
i wear blue light glasses like all the
time when i'm at my computer and i have
one pair so i'm like excited like i'll
have some diversity
these are perfect found them these are
kind of like harry potter-ish
but they're cute i actually think i'm
going with the wireframes
because i have some that are sort of
like this this is like one of our best
sellers actually
oh great
i just had a great day shopping and now
i'm here to get a juice
hello i'm i'm sorry to bother you can i
take a selfie with you such a huge fan
sure
thank you so much are you gonna get
something i would love to treat you
we're gonna get
two of the gingersnap green juices
all right i try to eat healthy
lots of fruits and veggies lots of fresh
food it is really important
how i fuel it affects my mood it affects
my health and my performance
thanks for hanging with me today and
thanks to my wells fargo active cash
card i earn
unlimited two percent cash rewards on
purchases
and it makes shopping that much more fun